welcome to the news at noon we begin
with a live picture out of washington
this noon hour
and that developing story you've been
watching right here on channel 8 from
capitol hill
after a suspect rammed his car into two
officers
resulting in the death of a capitol
police officer and leading to the driver
being shot and killed
you can see a very active scene there a
lot of officers still blocking that road
capitol police say the driver got out of
the vehicle while brandishing a knife
he was shot after ignoring commands from
police and
lunging towards them one officer died
another now being treated at the
hospital
right now lawmakers are away for recess
the incident though comes as the
washington region remains on alert
months after that mob stormed the u.s
capitol
as congress was voting to certify joe
biden's presidential win back in early
january
the capitol complex was placed on
lockdown as police continue to
investigate
out of an abundance of caution we will
bring you any developments
as we get them from capitol hill